Một mời thằng sau, tổng thống của quay nè bố lưu đi Miyachilenski Tuyên Bố,
khai đoàn đam phản của kia không có thầm quyền,
bàn về bánh đe chú quyền và toàn về lánh thổ.
Đây là vấn đề hiến pháp và thuộc thầm quyền chức kế của tổng thống.
Ông khẳng đềng sẵn sàng thảo lợi lãnh thổ duy nhất,
ở cấp cao nhất, bớt người đồng cấp ngạv là đi Miyachuchin.
Nhà lánh đạo của quay nè, tại thành định lập trường không công nhận mất kì phần lãnh thổ nào đã mất là của Ngà về mặt pháp liy.
Ông cũng bắt bảo yêu cầu giúp quan khởi các vùng lãnh thổ sôn mắt cơ vạc kìm sát.
Những mạnh đây là nghĩ vụ giến định và không có chuyện như đất thầm người dân.
Tuy bố này được đưa ra trường bố cạnh, Ngà bảo quay nè vừa tổ chức vong đàn phản tại thu nghĩ kì.
Chào đời các tài liệu liên quan tới lộ trình trấm giữ súng đột.
Tuy nhiên, hai bên chưa đàn được đồng thuận về việc tổ chức của gặp cấp cao.
Một số chuyên sát nhìn định ngà đăng trì hoảng đàn phản để cùng có lợi thế trên trình trường.